anda na olá boa tarde
antes de mais queria agradecer o convite
da organização para estar presente aqui
no tek ficar obviamente que é o irmão
jair o convite que é feito e ainda mais
simpático enternecedor estar entrando os
colegas de escape e poder fazer uma
apresentação a falar um pouquinho do que
é a praxe do estudo que teve a
oportunidade de fazer e da formação que
fui fazendo aqui no escape e que
certamente ainda continuarei a fazer
graças à formação contínua busca por
fontes sendo e falar um pouquinho
tamanho é que isso tudo conjugado me
ajudou entrar no mercado de trabalho e
também como é que o mercado de trabalho
pois me ajuda no estado
eu acho que veremos é importa o frio
inicialmente que é como membro do
conselho teremos ainda dois capitães
eventualmente alguma ideia o conceito
que possa transmitir será sempre um
conceito meu e uma idéia minha
não propriamente o conceito grande que é
por natureza um órgão consultivo e cujas
decisões são tomadas em conjunto e
portanto é voltar
portanto falar um pouquinho então do meu
percurso o porquê é que acho porque é
que eu vim pra ficar e como é que tudo
então se começar a desenvolver é eu
confesso que gosto na minha formação no
ensino superior
não era uma meta que eu tinha pré
estabelecida desde sempre
efetivamente não era é parte da família
mais próxima até não havia muita gente
facto com formação no ensino superior e
portanto não havia uma grande intenção
de procurar a formação ao nível do
ensino superior procurar o curso e
portanto acaba por surgir de uma forma
natural ao terminar os
ano no ensino secundário chegar ao final
e pensar então mas e agora você
trabalhar
houve uma fase em que fui trabalhando já
conciliar os todos e portanto não sabia
muito bem o que queria fazer tanto
mantenha no mercado de trabalho ea
procurar informação
qual seria a saída acabei por optar
ainda vai poder entrar no mercado
conseguir tradução literal chicago
a partir daí o fundamental mesmo para
alguém como eu que não tinha
efetivamente há uma noção certo daquilo
que teria o fundamental foi possível o
técnico vinha fazer aos que cá venho
estudar e vinha tirar o curso e portanto
é fundamental saber o que queria saber
por onde ia e perceber que é acima tudo
todos os passos que fossem tomates em um
centro no sentido de concluir os estudos
vão formar um profissional e como pessoa
mas porquê porque baixo porque tradições
acadêmicas efetivamente eu tinha um
leque um rol de possibilidades
portanto importa referir que
efetivamente para a china de 60 km texto
é é ajudaram muito na minha vida pessoal
e profissional continuam a fazê lo
é mais um exemplo se me permitem que
trago ela significa que a praxe seja
efetivamente o exemplo que todos nós ou
qualquer um de vocês tenha que seguir
não é o caso da praxe que isso era um
exemplo é que eu poderia ser uma sessão
na qual pode ser contrariado que o pode
ser um desporto é que o pode ser escrita
qualquer coisa como vossas significam e
com aquilo que se diga onde é que o
ligam à praça então acabou por surgir
uma forma natural
mais ou menos até cheguei cá e na praça
vai buscar como josé é virtual
a praça vai buscar mas foi buscar uma
forma se calhar menos habitual
eu entrei na segunda fase e tem uma
péssima é da tradição acadêmica uma
péssima idéia
alguns gente sem moto gritaria 10
eu tinha já colegas no ensino superior
uma vez que entra em campo mais tarde
com dois anos mais tarde e vizinhos não
entendo como é que vocês a não proibir
gritar nas ruas
isso não faz com gente não fazia sentido
nenhum e em certa medida não faz sentido
nenhum
acabou por ser apanhado na teia da praxe
não eu vou lá eu vou tentar perceber
então porque é que milhares de pessoas
na cidade do porto e milhões de pessoas
no país significam com a tradição
acadêmica ontem que haverá algo mágico
que certamente que os estudantes não
tomou conta da cabeça e não temos aqui
um conjunto de pessoas de menos
conseguem algum tipo de ritual que não
faz sentido
efetivamente assim começou a entrar e
divertir me
quando finalmente acabei por perceber um
pouco o conceito defende e continuar e
eu tenho a oportunidade de durante os
anos em que estive no escape de passar e
se calhar talvez essa foi a experiência
mais importantes passaram a comissão
plástica é enquanto o ativo tipo de
unidade com muitas situações às quais
não estava efetivamente habituado e
porquê porque se cria entre toda a
agenda e mais concretamente com os
alunos mais novos crianças ligações
emocionais que são um pouquinho difíceis
de explicar
é mas dando alguns exemplos
curiosamente já tive para ser passado
por situações mal entendido entre elas
por exemplo é eu sei que você pro sabe
qual fui ameaçado de processo por uma
irmã de uma aluna era uma aluna que
estava doente
quem fez mentalmente casos assim uma
aluna que estava doente uma hora com que
nós andávamos qual participem andávamos
a tentar contactar a família para
perceber saúde estava acompanhada
precisava do apoio nossa parte
eventualmente se ver o que cuidados é
que nós tínhamos que ter com essa lona
porque nós não sabemos lidar como
problema de saúde que essa aluna tinha
boa resposta que tivemos do tubo foi
simplesmente você só tenha que integrará
ea igual seja que não cuida dela e não é
preciso mais nada
e este tipo de situações que nós vamos
ter que cuidar é infelizmente com casos
sensíveis muitos é foi ajudando também
na minha formação pessoal na minha
formação profissional ajudou bastante
isso porque como é natural que como é a
face mais visível a organização do
evento a gestão de vendas gestão de
pessoas gestão do tempo é a dada altura
na minha formação eu concordo quando já
estava no mestrado e foi nessa fase em
que não porá também estava a trabalhar
com a comissão para checar é eu a dada
altura estava a trabalhar à parte me
estava a dar explicações curiosamente
está aqui uma uma ele falou né
já estava no terceiro ano do curso ela
tocando em vale já é em alturas a vaga
portanto as explicações que estava a
fazer um estágio curricular para
terminar o curso também tinha 10 para
desenvolver
eu trabalhava já como freqüência do
trator isto já ter concluído os estudos
estava na comissão de praxe é enfim
estava envolvido também em alguma ajuda
não diretamente mas indiretamente usava
também com anã na seção santos na altura
positiva pro colegas e portanto vê aqui
uma panóplia de situações que era
preciso gerir o tempo de exigir muita
coisa muitas pessoas em na via família e
ainda havia mais gente à nossa volta que
era preciso dar atenção e portanto
consegue gerir tudo isto e conseguir
manter o foco e aqui o fundamental no
curso foi o que prometeu construir
algumas destas características como esta
então depois dou para o mercado de
trabalho
infelizmente quando acabei o curso toda
aquela parceiro bragança que nós vamos
tendo quando estamos a trabalhar
enquanto estamos com os colegas enquanto
vamos na nossa convivência quando é
saudável entre nós quando sabemos
respeitar e essa base tanto quanto
trabalhamos com essa harmonia
nós vamos construindo muitas
competências porque enquanto estudantes
efetivamente quando estamos a construir
uma boa base uma base sólida de
competências que nos vão ajudar ao longo
da vida tanto a soft skills
também vamos buscar aumentar
efetivamente ao muitas dessas coisas que
me tiram mais tarde entrar com confiança
trabalhar com confiança
querer procurar o mercado queria ir
buscar mais informações que fez saber
que quer partilhar querer ir mais além
que foi muito bom foi transmitido e
muitos da vivência criativo no dia a dia
aqui junto com colegas mais velhos e
mais novos
importa aqui e aqui é fundamental dizer
mais do que isto
foi também na formação com os
professores que teve e aqui é que é
fundamental encontrar um equilíbrio
entre aquilo que nós fazemos portanto no
meu caso com uma dedicação na praxe mas
cada um dedicado aquilo que aumentar as
paixões que cada um de vocês tem que
encontrar esse equilíbrio
trago um pouco disso para o curso mas
valem muito mais do curso
procurem juntos professores procurem
junto da formação todos capita em tenha
escapado naturalmente teremos aqui
também algumas outras instituições que
também estarão certamente muito bem
preparados procurei mas eu ainda hoje
felizmente tem ótimo contacto e tem
muito saber e muita informação vou
buscar com muitas funções com que
trabalhei e já na altura portanto a
questão emocional cima prometeu voltar a
esse tema
acaba por ser muito mais do que qualquer
outra coisa que é praxe deu todas tanto
já falei há pouco mas principalmente
voltada para os álbuns mais novos alunos
que estão aqui temos alguns aqui do
trabalho os mais fortes e certamente
entendem isso é muito importante é muito
difícil por vezes no dia a dia
damos atenção que é necessária à gestão
à nossa volta está normal é humano mas
efetivamente quando nós estamos a falar
de uma tradição que vivo um pouco diz
que vive o tratamento que nós fazemos
ao agir como sabemos é praxe tem como
ideal o acolhimento à recessão e à
proteção do álbum mais novo
a ajuda lo sendo que depois tive vivo em
brincadeiras brincadeira dessas a que
nós chamamos do tal gozará o calor não
pode ser confundido não pode ser
confundido e portanto explicitamente na
praxe o convívio que nós fazemos o
tratamento
essa é fundamental para nos ajudar mais
tarde é ter uma conduta mais
profissional uma conduta mais séria
porque o trabalho que fazemos junto de
alguém efetivamente impediu efetivamente
não salvo a porta se abrir não sabe onde
procurar ajuda é que vai definir um
pouco aquilo que nós vamos fazer mais
tarde saberem atender da melhor forma as
necessidades da alguém pode surgir no
mercado e portanto mais tarde e esta tal
situação em que o próprio mercado nos
vai ajudando mais tarde aqui ou seja da
mesma forma que tiram do estudo é bom
por outro lado eo levam para os estudos
vão fazer um mercado de trabalho no
mercado de trabalho um dia pouco trouxe
muita dessa confiança eu fui buscar a
praxe de altitude muito essa confiança
mas isso foi agora desenvolvido e
portanto mantendo ligado a alguma forma
é no concelho grande uma uma num papel
digamos assim de consultor se assim
posso chamar é é a que eu trago mercado
de trabalho também já vai ajudar a
traçar uma perspectiva externa uma
perspectiva de quem está no dia a dia e
que se preocupa com o tipo de questões
esquece diariamente de pôr em prática e
portanto ao vir do mercado trabalho
traga uma relação diferente uma relação
da sociedade com uma relação externa
fora daquela prática do ritual que toda
a tradição acadêmica que carrega é e
isso permite me trazer para a mesa nos
assuntos que são publicados
é que o caos inspirado aqui o comunicado
também seb e ver e porque é que vocês
enquanto estão trajados enquanto estão
na prática podem melhorar e o técnico
pois podem aplicar e portanto é
importante fazer mudanças na prática a
mais do que muitas
duas coisas porque é uma tradição é
tradição é sempre resistente à mudança
mas a mudança importante
a mudança faz parte da nossa vida
nós mudamos a tradição também está
acumulada e não mudamos a tradição a sua
base na sua génese
mas é importante mudarmos 31 durante
todos estes anos estando a estudar
estamos na prazos também várias
situações estando sempre disponível
felizmente tive a oportunidade de fazer
o mesmo estrago em tradução imputação
especializadas em cinco anos com tudo
conjugado foi possível entrar no mercado
logo após a licenciatura foi possível
entrar e como todo projeto logo após
mostrado fizera asmus esteve na comissão
curso organizar várias conferências e
eventos no escape envolvido nas várias
organizações que vão surgindo e
extraordinárias que se vão formando
reinventando a comissão prazo continua
agora não consegue ter anos é possível é
possível conjugar é possível trabalhar
é importante que na tradição a tvm china
brasil e um carinho grande um pouco no
qual viemos há pouco numa numa palestra
foi transmitida é importante também que
nós não contribuamos para uma história
única relativamente à praxe e as
tradições acadêmicas sabemos qual é essa
história única que ouvimos diariamente
mas compete não e tem estado fora
completa quem está dentro completa até
nós e completo acima de tudo pra você
achou a quem está na tradição acadêmica
e aqui faltou causou um show para a
instituição que infelizmente nos cabe a
nós temos todo o apoio e todo o excesso
essa união que nos permita ter uma outra
visão acadêmica junto professores e da
direção é importante eo papel todos
saibam contribuir da melhor forma esse
jejum
vocês sejamos nós a mudar essa história
única
obrigado